[Music]
let's talk about the g-spot because that
is what I just want to get some medical
information out there what the hell I
did not see that
I know when they sexed up here they told
me that this was you know this was
representative of Conan's you know tone
inside actually this is actually but
it's supposed to be equivalent to a
vagina the vagina is u-shaped
banana-shaped
this is the this is a drain spout sewer
plate to you this is a vagina okay for
you what I want you to do is I know
okay I knew about this thing in high
school where do you think the g-spot I
don't want the entry I don't want to say
can you just tell me don't make me don't
make me guess cuz it will humiliate me
okay this is the front and then this is
the front this goes up to the uterus
don't know what's behind the but isn't
it okay
[Applause]
right
[Applause]
you don't know that they in pull and up
that come here there guys out there in
the audience somebody's gotta help me
out here they come hither like you're
calling your kid come on honey it's this
it's in about two inches in it feels
like a little raisin sort of less like
an orange peel role model for the men
out there in America this will be rare
it's it's everyone's gonna have their
minds Yuri we're all gonna pretend this
didn't happen